[Music]
A revolution is brewing in Iran
in a country we're removing your
headscarf could send you to prison for
years women are now burning them it's
part of a protest movement that is
posing a huge threat to the country's
brutal regime I saw a video of the
security forces bashing ahead of a woman
against the sidewalk they have to be
killing they have been blind from people
they have been beating people the
estimated average age of the protesters
is 15. it's hard to see young girls
dying in Iran
I've been covering the region now for 30
years I haven't seen anything parallel
to this
you really have to go back to 90 1979
the Islamic revolution to see anything
akin to a protest which has had so much
traction the successes of the Revolution
that founded the Islamic Republic could
offer
book about how to overthrow it
[Applause]
for these protests to become not just an
uprising which can succeed or fail but
actually result in the toppling of the
regime we need to look at areas of
change the first is the protesters
themselves
until now not having a leader has
actually been a source of strength
because there isn't a leader to arrest
and snuff out but at some point they
need to have again coherent messages
they need to have a body perhaps which
the outside world can start to engage
with and can be seen as a representative
of a future Iran in the 1979 Revolution
that leader was Ayatollah jomeni
protesters rallied in support of his
vision of creating an Islamic Republic
that gave him strength
it could be at some point that you do
get a figure who emerges you've already
had spokespeople who have come out and
said our next leader our next how many
is going to be a woman at this point
there are a few people that Iranian
people look up to
she has been fighting this fight for
eight years she started social
Disobedience campaign that was about
compulsory hijab
the son of the last king of Iran he has
some supporters among Iranians
a dentist and a writer in Canada he has
been very active he has organized
rallies in more than 120 cities outside
Iran
one thing that might be missing from the
puzzle that's pushing the revolution
forward is the Coalition outside Iran
and there are people there they're ready
but they have to come together they have
to come together
another lesson from 1979 is that regime
change takes time
[Music]
the practice have gone on longer pretty
much than any other that has been in the
history of the Islamic Republic but
they've still only been that's a
relatively small time compared to that
of 1979. now the protests that began in
the spring of 1978 didn't really reach
fruition
um for until over a year weeks could go
by with actually very little activity on
the street but there was clearly a sense
that they were building up into
something you're starting to get that
sense at the moment in Iran and many
young Iranians feel that they've just
burnt too many bridges to go back the
level of radicalism that you're seeing
on the streets now the level of violence
actually you're seeing on the streets
mobbings of policemen and of clerics
they've been torching uh Billboards of
the supreme leader they're getting to a
point where they know if they pull back
the regime is going to come right after
them and they can't afford to do that
thank you
but toppling a regime doesn't just
depend on the protesters
the regime itself needs to make mistakes
too
like the Shah did
[Music]
what really transformed the protests
Into Revolution were kind of serious
Mistakes by the Shah and his Security
Forces sometimes they would seem to be
weak and and Reign back and not do very
much other times they would overreact
there were massacres and the security
forces so far haven't committed the sort
of mistakes that those of the Shah did
in the run-up to the 1979 Revolution
then within the regime itself until now
you haven't seen any major defections I
think you would need to see some within
the system decide that they couldn't
stand by the Supreme Leader and given
the choice between the supreme leader
and the Iranians they were going to
choose their own population and I think
critically that has to happen within the
security forces as long as the security
forces stand by the system you know this
kind of hybrid form of clerical and
military rule is is going to sustain
itself and then I think also perhaps you
need to see external Powers start coming
off the fence
[Music]
until now that primary focus has been on
having a nuclear deal with the regime at
some point they need to start looking at
what a future Iran might look like and
to have some idea about what that
transition might look like I think could
bring stability not just for Iran but
for the region as a whole and perhaps
even for the world
for the time being Iranians are still
out protesting
there is a lot of fuel that keeps
Iranian people going day after day we
are fighting against oppressor so this
is a story of people winning as
oppressors
it's hard to see people dying in Iran
it's hard to see young girls dying in it
wrong
the hope is all we have and I hope is
all we have that we can you know get rid
of the surgery and have a different
government and have a bright future and
be able to sing and dance in the street
it's not too much to ask
thank you for watching to read more of
our coverage on Iran please click the
link and don't forget to subscribe